[Music]
The following program contains the
opinions of its host and guests, not
those of this network. The opinions
expressed are for
non-commercialformational purposes only.
Listeners are cautioned not to rely on
program content to treat or prevent
disease, but are advised to consult with
a licensed health care professional
where they live for diagnosis and
treatment of
disease. And now, the superstar of
alternative health and purveyor of
medical truth, Dr. Joel
[Music]
Wallik. Hello and welcome to Dead
Doctors Don't Lie. Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik,
your host, a veterinarian and physician.
And I'm here for kids and baby boomers
and seniors who don't want to die at
75.5 like their parents and
grandparents. I'm here for kids and baby
boomers and seniors who don't want to be
sick and miserable for the last 15 to 20
years of their life like their parents
and grandparents. We do have lines open.
Give us a call toll-free
1LE83792552. Again, that's toll-free
1LE83792552.
Well, that uh hurricane Ida has pretty
much demolished the entire total
infrastructure of Grand Isle, one of
these barrier islands on the uh Gulf
Coast of Louisiana, and pretty much made
it uninhabitable. So, our prayers go to
everybody who lives there, works there.
Our prayers go to everybody in
Louisiana, and of course, our fellow
human beings and our fellow Americans.
So, please share the prayers with us.
Okay? And then um these fires going,
they've just announced today that
they're evacuating 22,000 people from
the southern half of Lake Tahoe. All
right. What's going on here? Well, as a
Boy Scout um at um Blackberry
Lane School in Hanley Junior High School
um in St. Louis County, uh, Troop 495,
Boy Scouts, Eagle Scout, Explorer
Scouts. We got invited. We always were
involved in the fall in dealing with
forest fires and so forth. And I look at
these fires on TV that are going on uh
out in California, and they don't look
anything like the fires we used to
fight. We used to fight fires and the
fire was uh in the underbrush underneath
the trees. these fires and a little bit
un under the trees, but most of the
fires are in the crown of the trees and
in the air above the trees. The air is
literally burning. And I really spent a
couple of weeks exploring this and
figured out why this is happening and
why 7,000 professional firefighters
haven't been able to put out some of
these fires in three years. And they're
predicting that these won't be able to
be eliminated until the middle of
winter, maybe until a couple of years.
Okay? And that's because uh there's this
green algae growing in Lake Tahoe in the
shallow area. Okay. So that um um let's
see here a a photosynthesis can take
place. Okay. The
zoanthine algaes okay convert carbon
dioxide into
oxygen and carbon chains but they
require an enormous amount of nutrition.
Algae's require whether it's a reef
algaee or lake algaee's or ocean
algaee's require 20 different nutrients
to be able to pull off
photosynthesis and in Lake Tahoe the
shallow areas are covered with this
green algae and that people complain
about when they get a bloom okay because
if you know people don't like to be in
there with all the algae blooming and
all that kind of stuff well uh what we
need to do is get a army of boy scouts
girl scouts in um scuba gear and
mechanical brushes that that work, you
know, like a egg beater and and collect
all this algae and the fires will stop.
What's happening here is there are
marines. There's there's glacier marines
at the north end of Lake Tahoe. And as
the snows melt, it carries the minerals
out of these marines into the lake which
provide food for the algae to go through
photosynthesis. And then there's more
food for the algae to make
photosynthesis in the smoke, okay? In
the particles of smoke. And so he's
getting all this food. It's oxygen
driving this fire. It's oxygen
production driving this fire. So, we
need to get an army of people in that
lake right now and mechanically harvest
that algae and dry it and feed it to
some animals or something in the zoos.
Uh you know, we don't want to poison it
because it'll kill the lake and so we
have to harvest it. We need an army in
there before we hang up from this show.
get an army in there so the
photosynthesis will stop because the
marines are acting like dams and they're
just slowly leaking these minerals that
the um glaciers piled up there over
thousands of
years. And so um that plus the nutrients
in the smoke um the again the the
minerals in the marines which are
there's still remnants of these glaciers
the north end of Lake Tahoe. This these
are glacier lakes. These are glacial
lakes. And so it's reduction of oxygen
by the algae in Lake Tahoe that's
driving the fire. The 7,000 professional
firefighters can't put it
out. Okay. Dixie fire has been going for
what, three months? They still have it.
It's getting worse and worse and worse.
It's not, you know, like 10% contained.
Spare me. Okay. That's because these
glacial lakes are providing food for the
algae to generate more oxygen. And
that's what's driving these fires. We
need to harvest all these algaes and
make these lakes algae free or at least
reduce it by 90%. So maybe there'll be a
few frogs, tadpoles eat the algae, but
we can't have the whole bottom of the
shallow parts of the lake filled with
algae. Now this people say, "Well, when
was the last time you're at Lake Tahoe?
It's been many years." Well, how do you
know what you're saying? Well, um, you
know, I have
three post-docctoral fellowships. I have
degree in agriculture. I have a degree
in veterary medicine. I'm a physician.
my one my big post-docctoral fellowship,
my thesis is in the Smithsonian
Institute as a national treasure
represents 30, excuse me, 20,000
autopsies. Okay? And so I know what I'm
talking about. And the these people are
wonderful firefighters. They just know
to beat the fire down with a shovel. But
you can't beat all the oxygen that's
being produced in Lake Tahoe by this
algae because of the minerals coming out
of the marine on the north end of the
lake. Okay? And so this is fixable, but
they got to jump on this. Get every boy
scout, every girl scout, get every
professional diver, get an army of
people, get the National Guard, get them
in there and harvest all this algae with
mechanical brushes, harvest it, and make
that lake algae free for the moment, and
they'll be able to put out the fire in a
week. There you go. And so, just
remember, you heard it from me. Be back
after these messages.
You're listening to Dead Doctors Don't
Lie on the ZBS Radio Network with your
host Dr. Joel Wallik. If you'd like to
talk to Dr. Wallik, call between noon
and 1 Pacific at
831-6851080 toll-free 888-379-2552.
[Music]
If you're the type of person who likes
to volunteer and help others, this
should interest you. What better way to
help people than to help them with
improved health? Youngevity has been
helping people promote optimal health,
among others, for decades. Our approach
to health is drastically different than
medical doctors who mostly only treat
symptoms. As a veterinarian, Dr. Joel
Wallik discovered that many common
disease states are actually preventable
and reversible. Our mission is to help
people achieve overall health and
wellness and to help educate others to
achieve optimal wellness as well. And
here's the best part. While helping
people with their health and wellness,
you'll also be able to build your very
own homebased
business. For more information, contact
your local Young Associate. And don't
forget to ask about the homebased
business opportunity. Hello, Judy
Devilis here. If I could only afford to
get one product out of everything, that
product would be the ultimate classic.
It has the vitamins, the minerals, the
bioflavonoids. It even has grape seed
extract. The one product that would give
you just about everything under the sun
you would need for a perfect nutritional
program would be the ultimate classic.
By the way, people that are on the go,
it's very, very hard to take the liquids
with them when they go on their trip to
get their supplements in every day.
Well, you know something? You can use
the Ultimate Daily Tablets and the
mineral capsules. When I'm going on a
trip, if I have enough room, I just take
the two bottles with me. If not, just
use a little baggie and take a couple of
daily doses with you. It's very simple.
It's very easy. There's no mess, no
fuss, no refrigeration. Just take your
capsules, take your tablets, and you're
finished for the day. To order these
products, call your local Young Jeevity
distributor today.
[Music]
We're back with Dead Doctors Don't Lie
on the CBS radio network. Dr. Joel Wall
cure 95 crusade. We do have lines open.
Give us a call toll-free
1LE83792552. Again, that's toll-free
1LE8
3792552. And I want to go back to this
um Lake Tahoe thing. Uh this is not the
only place on earth this has happened.
This goes all the way back to
um millions and
millions years ago. Okay. Um when coal
became a thing. Coal became a thing 400
million years ago when um uh all of the
uh rivers and lakes and swamps were
blocked from from getting the silt,
okay, from glaciers and and um volcanic
eruptions and erosion, all that kind of
stuff by marines. And these marines
damned up these rivers and things, cut
off the food supply and all the algae
died and the oxygen disappeared and we
had these mass extinctions. Not there
was no cars, there was no fossil fuels
back then. Wiped out a thousand species
of animals uh for five times. Okay.
Okay. This is this is um because we shut
off the food supply which was coming
from the marines into these algaes
producing oxygen and and other things
amino acids and so forth
and and so u then the dead algae became
coal.
93% 93% of the world's coal comes from
swamps and lakes and rivers that had
algae in them. And that suddenly now
when the marine shut off the food supply
to these water bodies, all the algae
died and became
coal. That's 400 million years ago. And
we've been paying the price ever since.
And now everybody wants to blame global
warming on the fossil fuels. No, no, no.
It's not fossil fuels. It's not a
man-made thing. It happening 400 million
years before man came on Earth. It
happened um in the beginning. In the
beginning, biblically. Okay. Um in the
beginning, you have to appreciate that
um the only animals were in the water.
There was no oxygen on Earth since only
anorobic bacteria grew for millions of
years. Duh. Okay, Doug. What pearls of
wisdom you have? Well, I thought we'd
talk a little bit about the health
benefits of honey as it is an
alternative to sugar. Studies have shown
that uh superfood can help boost your
brain health and suppress a cough. It's
not just good in your oatmeal. It's a
natural sweetener. Can also be used as a
natural home remedy remedy that is for
cuts and scrapes. Honey is made up
primarily of water and sugar mostly
fructose and glucose along with fructo
oligosaccharide or FOS a prebiotic it is
low calorie and also it's not digestible
so it doesn't affect your blood sugar
levels and this FOS offers several
health benefits according to a study
foss can help protect you from unhealthy
bacteria and it foss has been found to
suppress the growth of claustrdium ium
perfor a toxic bacteria linked to food
poisoning can also help uh decrease
cholesterol levels. In an animal study,
researchers found that it helped reduce
body both weight and cholesterol levels
in rats and dogs. FOS is also full of a
soluble dietary fiber. In a separate
study, se uh scientists discovered that
FOS can help reduce and prevent
constipation. Aside from being a
prebiotic, it also contains essential
vitamins and minerals like calcium,
magnesium, and potassium. Uh, healing
benefits are mostly linked to its
antimicrobial and anti-inflammatory
properties. I didn't realize there's
over 300 different kinds of honey in
America. And the color and scent and the
flavor of honey, all determined by the
flower, nectar that the bee uses to
produce it. So, there you go. Yeah.
Yeah. And of course, honey's been a
therapy item
for all kinds of healers going back to
the beginning of human time, human, you
know, human populations. And so honey is
one of the first um medicinal products
out there. And then there was salt and
salt water and that kind of stuff. And
so honey's been around a long time and
um it'll be around for a long time after
that because everybody loves it. And um
so yeah, we use a lot of it. Um I I I
put it on fresh artichokes. I put it on
um let's see here. I put it on rice. I
put it on rice. We don't use bread
because of the gluten. So we can't put
it on bread. Can't put it on oatmeal
because it has gluten. So we put it on
artichokes and rice. Back after these
messages. You're listening to Dead
Doctors Don't Lie on the ZBS Radio
Network with your host, Dr. Joel Wallik.
If you'd like to talk to Dr. Wall, call
between noon and 1 Pacific at
831-6851080. Toll-free 888-379-2552.
[Music]
In recent years, several studies have
discovered the healthy benefits of
drinking coffee. Youngevity has now
taken it a step further with an entire
product line of healthy coffees from
Youngevy's Java Fit selection of
topshelf gourmet coffees. All Java Fit
coffees are made from 100% premium hand
selected Arakova coffee beans grown in
the finest regions of Latin America.
Carefully roasted creating a delicious
rich fullbodied flavor. Try Java's
original roast. A perfect blend of
mellow and smooth with just the right
fullbodied depth to make an aromatic and
enjoyable cup of coffee. traditional as
well as organic and fair trade options.
Also available in 30count single cup or
24count single pot packs. Contact your
local FDI Young distributor to get
Javalution coffees. And don't forget to
ask about Homebased business
opportunities. If you're looking for a
quality multivitamin and mineral
product, grab yourself Young's Beyond
Tangy Tangerine, a blend of
plant-derived minerals combined with
vitamins, amino acids, and other
beneficial nutrients. This all-natural
product contains no starch, wheat, or
yeast with no artificial sweeteners or
preservatives, and it's glycemic
friendly. Each scoop of the Neutra
Crystals contain equal amounts of all
the nutrients. It starts out as a
liquid, then is freeze dry to ensure
each scoop has the same nutrients as the
last scoop. So, if you want to get your
hands on a quality nutritional
supplement designed to give the body the
raw materials it needs to rebuild,
Youngevity's Beyond Tangy Tangerine is
available in one lb canisters and also
in 30count onthe-go stick packs. Contact
your locality associate and get this
great multivitamin and mineral product.
And don't forget to ask about the
homebased business
opportunity. You've listened to
physician and veterinarian Dr. Dr. Joel
Wallak helped many people on the Dead
Doctors Don't Buy Talk Radio program.
You've also heard hundreds of people
tell how Dr. Wallak and Youngevity
products have changed their lives. If
you're now convinced that Dr. Wallak is
on to something and you want to try
Youny's premium quality products for
yourself, we can connect you with a
distributor that serves your local area.
Simply call our special helpline
voicemail at 313-4443463.
That's
313-444-3463. Call right now and leave
your name, telephone number, or email
address and we'll see to it that the
right person contacts you shortly.
Remember the phone number
313-4443463. That's
313-4443463. Call now to change your
life. That's 313-4443463.
[Music]
We're back with Dead Doctors Don't Line
the CBS Radio Network. Dr. Joel Wallik
here for Young 95 Crusade. We do have
lines open. Give us a call toll-free
1LE83792552. Charmaine, you there? I'm
here.
Okay. Have you ever been to Lake Tahoe?
Yeah, of course.
And did you realize that it was a
glacial lake? Did you realize that there
was a a um glacier marine at the north
end of it of the lake and it was feeding
all these minerals slowly seeping these
minerals into the lake and this is why
we have all these algaes blooming in
there producing oxygen which drives
these forest fires. I know that it's too
cold to ever swim in and I know there's
lake snow at the top of all the
mountains around the lake. I remember
seeing that. Yep.
And so uh this is and people say well
well I mean you didn't do any exper I
don't have any experiments I just I know
how things work and when people put out
data that the bottom of the lake and all
the shallow areas are covered with this
green algae um it's you know many inches
thick and well that's what these algaes
do. They produce, especially with a
source of fertilizer like the silt that
comes from these marines, um these this
they produce oxygen. That's what they
do. And these fires are not your typical
wood burning, brush burning fires. I
mean, I you know, like I said, in my
early days as a scout, we spent every
every fall dealing with forest fires
along with the professional foresters
and forest fighters and forest
firefighters and so forth.
And so we need to get everybody we can
to get their scuba gear on, get some
mechanical brushes and some bags and
collect all the seaweed or algae. I
guess it's not seaweed, algae. Algae in
Lake Tahoe and dry it someplace else and
feed it to animals. But get it out of
there and it'll stop the oxygen
production. Well, guess what? It'll be
easy to put the fires out without
oxygen. That's true.
That's why they can't put these Yeah.
And so that that's why they can't put
these fires out. And I knew it had to do
something with that. But then today in
the news, they're talking about all this
algae in Lake Tahoe. And um they don't
know what's going to happen to the algae
when the fires come through there. Well,
um the fires won't hurt the algae
because the algae are, you know, 2 feet
of water. So the fires aren't going to
hurt the algae. will just put more um
ash and stuff like that which is ash has
minerals in it which is going to feed
the algae more food and they'll produce
more oxygen. So we have to get people in
there. We need an army of people in
there ASAP to harvest all that algae out
of there, use it usefully. So, you know,
we're conserving it, not just throwing
away, but we got to cut off the oxygen
supply to these fires. And that's that's
the basis of this. And
um that's why my thesis is in the
Smithsonian Institute as National
Treasure uh because I can read things um
based on other people's data. Just like
for hundreds of years, every medical
doctor knew that cystic fibrosis
muscularity were genetic. No, they're
both nutritional deficiencies. For over
a hundred years, every doctor knew that
um babies who died of centime syndrome
were laid upon by their mothers. They're
in the same bed together and the
mother's laid on them. No, all three of
those diseases are nutritional
deficiencies. 98% of those babies who
died of sediment death
syndrome were um in the crib by
themselves. They weren't in bed with
their mothers. Only 2% were in bed with
their mothers and they weren't laid on
by their mothers. They died of
hypertrophy cardopathy heart disease.
The same heart disease that that um
athletes die from. And you you have a
high school education. You know what
causes hypertrophy cardopathy heart
disease. Charmaine, you don't have to do
the research. You just know how to get
the information. We'll be back after
these messages. You're listening to Dead
Doctors Don't Lie on the ZBS Radio
Network with your host, Dr. Joel Wallik.
If you'd like to talk to Dr. Wall, call
between noon and 1 Pacific at
831-6851080. Toll-free 888-379-2552.
[Music]
You've listened to physician and
veterinarian Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik helped
many people on the Dead Doctors Don't
Buy Talk Radio program. You've also
heard hundreds of people tell how Dr.
Wallak and Youngevity products have
changed their lives. If you're now
convinced that Dr. Wallak is on to
something and you want to try Youny's
premium quality products for yourself,
we can connect you with a distributor
that serves your local area. Simply call
our special helpline voicemail at
313-4443463.
That's
313-444-3463. Call right now and leave
your name, telephone number, or email
address, and we'll see to it that the
right person contacts you shortly.
Remember the phone number
313-444-3463. That's
313-444-3463. Call now to change your
life. That's 313-4443463.
Hi, this is Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik, your
host of Dead Doctors Don't Lie. If
you're interested in a colon cleanse,
blood cleanse, liver cleanse, you know,
in the classical herbal way, you want to
ask your YoungeJity associate for Herbal
Rainforest. Herbal Rainforest has 16
herbs, 16 cleansing herbs, classic
cleansing herbs, and 77 plant minerals.
That's right. And these are all organic.
It doesn't get any better than that. and
you're busy day and you're around all
these toxins out there in your workplace
on the way home, going to work, in your
food, in the air, in the water, you need
herbal rainforest. I guarantee you it
will give you a cleanse. You can control
the dose. It's a liquid. It tastes good.
It doesn't get any better than this. A
colon that's happy makes you happy.
Nothing better than a happy colon.
Herbal Rainforest. Clean it out. For
more information on this product or
others you've heard about on the Dead
Doctors Don't Lie Radio program, call
your local Young Associate today. And
don't forget to ask about homebased
business opportunities.
Greetings everyone. Judy Dilbus here.
What do you think of when you hear the
words tangy tangerine? Well, I think of
like a sweet, tangy tasting something.
Well, what I'm referring to is the
ultimate tangy tangerine. It's a
fantastic product. It has everything you
need. And a great benefit is it's very,
very delicious. It's very easy to drink.
I've suggested it even to youngsters,
even children like it. Even little guys,
even little girls. They come right into
my office. Their parents can't get them
to take those chewables. And besides
that, they're not as good as tangy
tangerine. And I give them a little
taste of that. And you know something,
they're pleased as punch. So if it's
good for a child and it tastes
delicious, why not you? There's no
excuse not to take a vitamin when it
tastes as good as that does. So, how
about it? Tangy Tangerine should be the
answer to all of your nutritional
program problems. For more information
or to order, call your Youngevity
distributor today. And don't forget to
ask about Youngevity homebased business
opportunities. This is the ZBS radio
network.
[Music]
We're back with dead doctors don't lie
on the CBS radio network. Dr. Joel Wall
here 95 crusade. We do have lines open.
Give us a call toll-free 1LE83792552.
And we did finally pass the 1918 1919
record of the Spanish flu where the
Spanish flu killed 657,000 Americans in
two years. We're just going on the, you
know, the two-year mark here with the CO
19 and all its varants. We just yet last
night passed
658, 103. So
we're, 103 over the Spanish flu record.
um number of infections as of this
morning is
40,131,681. Okay. And so we have
surpassed it there too. So it's one of
those things where um what's going on
here? Why do we have these things? Well,
our immune systems are not functioning
properly because everybody's eating
gluten. Very few people supplement
properly and vaccines don't kill bugs.
And everybody in the medical field
banked everything. They banked their
reputations. They bank your life on
vaccines. Well, the vaccines aren't
going to work without you taking
supplements and avoiding gluten. You
have to be able to absorb the nutrition
so your bone marrow, your immune system
can actually respond to the vaccination.
Vaccinations do not kill viruses. That's
why there's so many breakthroughs,
infections, and uh it's not scary when
you know the cause, but you have to be
proactive. You have to get rid of all
the bad foods. You got to take the 90s
essential nutrients. You know, get the
big hammer. Get the 215 nutrients. Take
the healthy brand and heart pack. Take
the MSM. Take the vitamin D3. Take the
killer biotic. Take our zinc tablets.
Take our vitamin C tablets. Do all this
kind of stuff you can do. Stay away from
the gluten so your intestines will heal
and absorb and then your vaccines will
work. But doctors made a huge mistake by
banking their future and your life on
vaccinations. Okay, Doug, let's go to
callers. All right, let's head to
California. And Marlene, you're on with
Dr. Wallik. Hello, Marlene. You're on
the air. Can we see you? Yes. Hi, this
is Marlene. Um, I was calling because I
stepped into a like a small nail
yesterday on my foot and um I don't know
if I should go to the doctor for that or
I just drink some medicine or I can cure
it myself. I don't know. Okay. Well,
tell me what you're talking about. It's
like when you you hurt your foot, is it
an open wound or is it just painful or
what?
Oh, well, um it was in the parking lot.
Um, I was walking and then like I just
felt like a poke on my foot. It went
through my sandal and Okay. Okay. Stop.
My foot. Okay. You said, "Wait a minute.
Stop." You said you had a poke in your
foot. It went through your sandal. Did
you step on a nail, broken glass? I
mean, what are we talking about here?
That was a small nail. It was a small
nail. Okay. Well, if you have a puncture
wound from a small nail, I would go, you
know, I would go see a doctor and get
some antibiotics and all that kind of
stuff and get and and get some wound
cleaner and clean it out. But in the
meantime, um, how old are you and how
much you weigh?
Um, I'm 40 and I weigh 165.
Okay. Do you have any young Do you have
any products in your household?
Um, I
have Hold on. Let me see what we have.
Do you have any I have Yes. Okay. Stop.
I don't have time for you to look
through your closet. Okay. Do you Do you
have a colloidal silver?
Yeah, I have some. Okay. If you have
colloidal silver, what I want you to do
is put two droppers full under your
tongue. 30 minutes for each meal and 30
minutes before bedtime. I also want you
to soak a cotton ball with the colloidal
silver and put it on that puncture wound
and wrap it and put a a tight sock on
it. And I'd still go today to see a a
doctor and get some antibiotics in case
that puncture wound um pushed a a
bacterial bug up in there and caused an
infection. So I still have you know
professional person look at that. But in
the meantime um you can wash it with
soap and water. You can use our hand
sanitizer and use a colloidal silver
like I say soak a cotton ball with it
but also take some orally so it'll go
through the bloodstream and attack any
bugs from the inside. But go see a
doctor and then call us. Let us know
what they say. But you can do a lot of
first aid. Let's see how bad it is. Back
after these messages. And that does open
a line. If you'd like to talk to Dr.
wallet. Call between noon and 1 Pacific
at
831-6851080. Toll-free
888-3792552. Lines open.
[Music]
[Applause]
You've listened to physician and
veterinarian Dr. Joel Wallik help many
people on the Dead Doctors Don't Buy
Talk Radio program. You've also heard
hundreds of people tell how Dr. Wallak
and Youngevity products have changed
their lives. If you're now convinced
that Dr. Wallak is on to something and
you want to try Youny's premium quality
products for yourself, we can connect
you with a distributor that serves your
local area. Simply call our special
helpline voicemail at
313-444-3463. That's
313-4443463. Call right now and leave
your name, telephone number, or email
address and we'll see to it that the
right person contacts you shortly.
Remember the phone number
313-4443463. That's 313-4443463.
Call now to change your life. That's
313-444-3463.
I am Judy Dilbus. Here I am speaking to
you again. I just wanted to tell you
that recently I started drinking the
whey shakes again, the chocolate whey
shake. And you need to remember the whey
shake isn't just for losing weight. It's
a fantastic place to get your great
protein. And if you're trying to gain
weight, you can take it along with your
meals. And the best part is if you want
to just have a great protein shake, do
like I do. Put it over ice, stir it up,
and you can sip on it for 20 minutes to
an hour. I do it every single day. I
absolutely love it. You need to get back
to it, too. It's really good for you.
And it makes not fat, but it makes
muscle after you work out. And you can
also mix it up in a blender with an egg
and you have the most incredible health
protein shake. Or mix it with a little
water, stir it up, and you have a little
pudding. And who doesn't like pudding?
For more information or to order, call
your Youngevity distributor today. And
don't forget to ask about Young Jevity
homebased business
[Music]
[Applause]
opportunities. We're back with Dead
Doctors Don't Lie on the CBS Radio
Network. Dr. Joel Wallally cure for
Young 95 Crusade. We do have lines open.
Give us a call toll-free
1LE8379-2552. And Doug, let's go to
callers. All right, let's head to
Canada. And Charles, you're on with Dr.
Wallik.
Well, Charles, you're on the air. How
can we help you, sir?
Yes. Good evening, Doc. Um, I'm trying
to help someone. She has dementia,
diabetes, high blood pressure.
Okay. I heard diabetes, high blood
pressure. What was the first one?
Um, you said there was a a woman
dementia. Oh. Oh, dementia. Dementia.
Okay. Yeah. So, she Okay. All right. And
how And how old is this person?
She's 70.
70. Okay. Do you know how much she
weighs?
She weighs 110 10 pounds. Okay.
Charmaine, you there? Yes, I'm here. Of
course. Okay. Charles friend. She's
about your size, 110 pounds. She's got
high blood pressure. She's got diabetes.
And she's got dementia. Okay. So, what
are you going to do for her? Well, she's
got to get off the bad stuff. No wheat,
barley, ry oats, no fried foods, no
burnt animal fat, and no oil. And then I
would get her on a healthy brain and
heart pack. I would add the ultimate
daily classic, the sweeties,
uh some uh
destress and some synaptive and some MSM
just for the heck of it and vitamin D3
for absorption. Okay. And then how many
A's would you have her eat at 110
pounds? How many A's you eat? Uh at
least I eat
two. She should eat four because she's
got dementia. Yeah. Yeah. It needs see
you have to appreciate everybody that
75% of your brain weight is cholesterol.
You do not want to be on statin drugs to
lower cholesterol because you will get
dementia. And of course there's all
kinds of dementia. You can have blocked
arteries in the brain get what's called
vaser dementia. Um there's a dozen
different types of dementia. Seenile
dementia long before long before there
was Alzheimer disease. Alzheimer disease
is a physician caused disease. It is
caused by the advent of the drugs in the
category of statin drugs because it
lowers cholesterol which took all the
cholesterol out of people's brains and
they got Alzheimer disease. Okay. Thank
you, Charmaine. Give us a call every
couple of weeks, Charles, and let us
know how this lady is doing because she
can improve very quickly. Okay. Uh Doug,
let's go to callers.
All right, let's head to Kansas. And
Margaret, you're on with Dr. Wallik.
Hello, Margaret. You're on the air. How
can we help you?
Yes. Thank you for taking my call and I
sure need your help. Okay. How can we
help you?
Hello. How can we help you?
Hello Margaret.
Looks like we lost her. Let's go on to
San Diego, California. And Tomasa,
you're on with Dr. Wallik.
Ombasa, how can we help
you?
Hello. Is anybody home? Yeah. Hi, this
is Tomasa, Dr. Wallace. Okay, you got to
be quick. What's our problem? How can I
help you? Yeah. Oh, I just want to give
my testimony uh about how um about how
90 for life um taking uh 90 for life are
helping me a lot. Okay. Um and my um I
was obese obesity. Uh I was How much did
you um How much did you weigh?
165 and now I'm 142.
Okay. How tall are you? Yeah. And I'm
52.
Oh, okay. Yeah. And Okay. And after
taking this um this uh night for life um
it heal heal my body and uh I feel more
energetic. I'm doing um more uh product
product things like uh I'm doing a lot a
lot of things now. I move more. I do
exercise. I was s c sedentary. I don't
know is that a word? Sedentary. I do
sedentary. Yep. Yeah. I didn't do no uh
no uh uh exercise and now I'm I'm moving
moving more. Okay. Well, thank you so
much for the testimony. If you would
call us every couple of weeks and kind
of give us a progress report as you go
along here because at 5'2, I'd like to
see you weigh 110. So, you still need to
lose about 30 32 pounds. Okay. But going
from 165 to 142 is good. Excellente.
Okay. And so let's keep going here. Um
but the fact that you're doing more
things and you feel you you felt so
good. You wanted to to share your
successes with our listeners. Thank you
so much for doing that. You're going to
help a lot of people. Okay, Doug, let's
go to callers.
Let's head back to Kansas and try
Margaret again. Margaret, you're on with
Dr. Wallik.
Thank you for taking my call. Yes,
ma'am. How can we help you? I had I had
laser surgery on my left
eye. They told me I would see beautiful
after I had that surgery done. Mhm. And
now I am black blind.
Okay. Now, did they tell you you had a
cataract?
Okay. Did they tell you had a cataract?
You had mac regeneration? What did they
tell you you had? Why did they want to
do the the laser surgery?
I had very weak eyes and I did have my
cataract removed.
Okay. But at the same time I never
pardon. Was it the same
time all at once or did you have the
cataract removed a month earlier or? No,
the cat
cataract was removed some time ago.
Okay. So after they removed the
cataracts, you could see, but then when
they did the surgery, you went blind.
Okay. How much do you weigh, Margaret?
What's your body weight?
121.
Okay. And how tall are you?
55.
Okay. And what's your age?
Oh goodness. 83.
Okay. And do you have any other issues?
Any high blood pressure, diabetes?
I have I am diabetic but I control it by
diet. Okay. And then do you have any
gray hair? I do have
Yeah. Apologize. You you do have high
blood pressure.
Yes. I I have trouble with my blood
pressure and I need dialysis. Oh,
dialysis. Okay. Okay. That's Thank you
for telling us that. Uh, all right,
Charmaine. Here's here's Margaret. She's
on diialysis. She's um 83 years old.
She's a diabetic. She's got high blood
pressure. Um, she's blind in one eye.
She had a cataract removed from that eye
some years ago. And she feels weak and
doesn't have any energy. What can you do
for her? Well, first of all, she's got
to get on a gluten-free diet. Very
important. No wheat, barley, ry oats, no
fried foods, no burnt animal fat, and no
oil. And then at her weight and
everything, I would get her on a healthy
brain and heart back. I would add the
ultimate daily
classic and I would also add the OCut
for the eyes and vitamin D3 for
absorption. And uh I would also add MSM
and fucoid Z. And as far as energy goes,
I would if it was me, I would take the
rebound. I would drink the rebound for
energy because it's it doesn't make you
jittery or anything. Just gives you nice
energy. It makes you feel alive. Yeah,
that was Yeah, that was made for
professional athletes, Olympic athletes.
It has 75 minerals in it and 25 bottoms
amino acids. And the diialysis, uh the
you you mentioned the ultimate daily
classic tablets. I'd have her take three
of those twice a day. That's two bottles
a month. They're designed to support and
promote healthy blood flow through
um um plugged arteries and uh support
healthy blood pressure. Now u Margaret
um how many days a week do you get
diialysis? Three days a week, six days a
week. How many days a week do you get
diialysis?
Three days a week. Okay. Well, give us a
call after, you know, every two weeks
and tell us how your diialysis is going.
tell us your blood pressure, your
diabetes, and how your vision is going
because we have some great great
testimonies with people with your same
scenario, the same story you got. We're
looking forward to a good good good
message from you every two weeks. We'll
be back after these messages. You're
listening to Dead Doctors Don't Lie on
the Z Radio Network with your host, Dr.
Joel Wallik. If you'd like to talk to
Dr. Wallet calls at
831-6851080. Toll-free
[Music]
888-379-2552. Imagine a rich, decadent
chocolate that's actually good for you.
Youngevy's Triple Treat Chocolate is
just that, an antioxidant-rich dark
chocolate complete with probiotics to
aid in proper digestion. This all-
naturatural product contains no
preservatives. And for those with
dietary restrictions, it's gluten-free,
dairyfree, glycemic friendly, and kosher
certified. Not only does Triple Treat
dark chocolate taste fantastic, it
contains super antioxidant blueberries
to absorb free radicals with an oric
value of
16,936 per piece. Triple Treat Chocolate
also contains a proprietary blend of
probiotics with over 500 million live
healthy bacteria per 8 grams at the time
of manufacture with 80% reaching the
intestines, which is much more than most
live culture yogurts. If you'd like to
learn more about nutritional
supplementation, call your local
Youngevity Associate. And don't forget
to ask about homebased business
opportunities. Hey, if you're like me,
your life is hectic. You don't know
where you're going to be next. Between
kids and family and in-laws and work and
traffic and everything else that's
driving me crazy right now. My life is
insane. I bet your life's insane as
well. When do we have time to get every
single nutrient we need to be healthy?
When? Well, I've got a tip for you. Take
a product called Pollen Burst. It's so
simple, even I can do it. All you have
to do is open the package, pour it in
water, mix it up, and bam, you're ready
to go. It tastes great. It's not one of
those medicine tasting things. It tastes
great, low in calories, helps curb your
appetite, gives you natural energy that
doesn't let you crash. Gives you your
vitamins, minerals, nutrients,
everything from the plant world. And I
got to tell you, for a busy person like
me or a busy person like you, we need
simple. We need good. Palmer is your
answer. Tastes great. Try it and you'll
feel better. Call your local Youngevity
distributor to find out how Pollen Burst
can make you feel better. And don't
forget to ask about homebased business
opportunities. You've listened to
physician and veterinarian Dr. Joel
Wallik helped many people on the Dead
Doctors Don't Buy Talk Radio program.
You've also heard hundreds of people
tell how Dr. Wallak and Youngevity
products have changed their lives. If
you're now convinced that Dr. Wallak is
on to something and you want to try
Youny's premium quality products for
yourself, we can connect you with a
distributor that serves your local area.
Simply call our special helpline
voicemail at
3134443463. That's
313-444-3463. Call right now and leave
your name, telephone number, or email
address and we'll see to it that the
right person contacts you shortly.
Remember the phone number
313-4443463. That's
313-4443463. Call now to change your
life. That's
[Music]
313-4443463. We're back with Dead
Doctors Don't Lie on the CBS radio
network. Dr. Dr. Joel Wallik here for
Young 95 Crusade and Doug. Let's go to
callers or emails. All right, let's head
to Texas. And Debbie, you're on with Dr.
Wallik. Oh, Debbie, you're on the air.
Hi. Hi, Dr. Wallik. Uh, great to talk to
you, sir. I think you're a brilliant
physician, man, and I have a lot of your
books and your famous CD, and I try my
best to abide by what you teach. Um, my
question, sir, is this. You're so
welcome. I'm trying to do this briefly
and not talk too much. Um, we only have
a couple of moments here. Yeah. Yeah.
Getting to my question. Um, back in May,
I was hospitalized for a week. I had an
infection that I developed, a felen
finger infection due to diabetes that I
had also developed recently. And I had a
35, 31, and 25 years ago gestational
respectively and didn't have it for the
last 40 something years or what have not
40ome years, 30 something years. I'm
only 56. Okay. So, anyway, back to my
question. And I was hospitalized in May
for about a week to treat that. I came
home on all sorts of antibiotics like
Levofluxin,
uh, Doxycycling. I forget, you know,
what else right off hand here, but they
sent me home on quite a bit. Well, I've
pretty much gotten over all of that.
Stopped taking antibiotics about eight
weeks ago. And I went, you know, for a
doctor's visit. They asked me if I
wanted the pneumonia vaccine. And let me
tell you, doctor, in my whole entire
life, I've rarely been hospitalized just
to have my three kids. I never take
pharmaceuticals. Just once in a while,
like if I ever rarely get a cold or flu,
I would take um Alka-Selt plus liquids
because I kind of have trouble with
pills. And so anyway, um a few days
after I got the Numacco 23 vaccine, I
went walking at a walking trail near my
home. And this has never ever happened
to me before. I don't smoke. I used to
drink in moderation, but I I cut that
off. Okay, we got to go quickly. We've
only got a moment. Yeah. Yeah. So,
here's a here's the deal. I I was
walking briskly around the track uh when
I first got out of the hospital, no
problems. I did four laps without
stopping. And then a couple of days,
that's backtracking, a couple of days
after getting the vaccine, when I went
to go walk, it started, I started to
have pain in my chest, like muscle or
soreness in my chest. I'm like, "Oh my
god, what is this?" And I kept walking.
I stopped resting a few minutes. Kept
walking. I did six laps, but I had to
stop after each one and rest for about
four or five minutes. And I felt like
the Lord was showing me that it was due
to the vaccine, which I had never before
in my life. Okay. Stop. Stop. How much
do you weigh?
Um 157. And how old are you? I'm 56.
Okay. How tall are you?
Uh about almost 5'3,
53 and a half, somewhere around there.
Okay. So, Charmaine, what would you do
for Debbie here? She has a history of of
diabetes. She has a history of an
infected hand or fingers and um she has
chest pain now. What would you do for
her? Well, she's got to avoid the bad
stuff. No wheat, barley, ry roast, no
fried foods, no burnt animal fat, and no
oils. Then I would get her on one
healthy brain and heart pack and one
healthy blood sugar pack. And I would
add to it the ultimate daily classic. I
would have her start taking some killer
biotic for a while.
MSM. Yep. MSM of course. Uh vitamin D3
for absorption.
And uh what about colloidal silver? Yes.
Colloidal silver with the color biotic
for a while. Yep. Yep. And uh there you
go. Okay. Very good. So if you try these
things here, Debbie, and uh you know, if
the doctor sent you home with
medication, continue to take that until
the prescription, you know, runs out as
supposed to do. But um uh you you want
to support your immune system. You want
to avoid all the bad foods so you can
maximize absorption of the nutrition. Uh
vaccines don't work real well without
your body participating. Um they don't
kill viruses, bacteria, fungus, or
yeast. And so, you know, it sounds like
uh and there's chest pain. It could be
that you have a back problem causing
squeezing of some of these um uh
peripheral nerves that come off of the
spinal cord, whether it's the chest or
your low back. Um but then it could be
also stuff going on with your lungs,
your arteries, and your heart. Who
knows? And Char, did you say Ultimate
Daily Classic tablets? I hope I did. I
if I didn't, I meant to. Yeah. Okay. So,
I want you to take three of those twice
a day and then give us a call every two
weeks. Take give us a call and go back
visit the doctor. Let us know what they
say and we'll walk you through this.
Okay. Well, thank you so much everybody.
Great information today. Thank you so
much Charmaine. Superlative job as
usual. Thank you Doug. Superlative job
as usual. God bless each and every one
of you. God bless our troops. God bless
our Navy Seals. God bless the American
flag. God bless our national anthem. And
God bless America.
[Music]
La when those aches and pains in your
knees, elbows, hands, shoulders and back
crop up. Reach for Youngevities CM
cream. Put CM cream on a Q-tip and put
it in your ear canal for relief from
headaches and situs pressure. A topical
temporary relief from minor aches and
pains of muscles and joints associated
with strains, sprains, and simple
backachches. Why take aspirin or
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drugs
that can cause stomach bleeding and
liver damage? Just apply CM cream
liberally to the affected areas and
within 20 minutes or so, you'll have
relief from those nagging, minor aches
and pains. You'll feel better for up to
four to 5 hours. So, the next time you
have achy joints or muscles, do what I
do. Reach for CM cream for relief. And
for systemic relief, reach for CM Plus
capsules. If you'd like to learn more
about nutritional supplementation, call
your locality associate. And don't
forget to ask about homebased business
opportunities.
AM1340 KOMY Lasselva Beach, Watsonville,
Santa Cruz. A surface of ZBS.
Breaking news this hour from town
hall.com. I'm John Scott. The remnants
of Ida are blowing into New England. a
band of severe weather that's flooding
low-lying communities and forcing
evacuations in Virginia, Maryland, and
Pennsylvania. A tornado watch remains in
effect for parts of the Appalachins. And
forecasters are warning that potentially
deadly floods could happen in cities
from New Jersey to Boston. A suspect
being sought after one student was
injured in a shooting at a North
Carolina high school. The shooting
occurred at Mount Taber High School in
Winston Salem. The campus has been
secured. No word on whether the suspect
is a student. More unflattering poll
results for President Biden. Bob Agnu
reports. A majority of Americans
responding to Arasmus and reports
national telephone and online survey say
the president should resign over the
botch handling of the US pull out from
Afghanistan. 52% say the affair was
handled so poorly Biden should step
down. 39% disagree and